we're on day three of the convention the
question is how's it going so far
well former democratic candidate
marianne williamson has been following
it closely
she describes the experience as quote
like binge watching a marriott
commercial
that's about right pretty unappetizing
platitudes heaped upon cliches smothered
in a
thick sauce of self-righteousness and
stupidity
no normal person could eat what the dnc
is serving this week
we tune in because it's our job so far
the main excitement has been watching
just how shamelessly they can lie
the goal appears to be complete reality
inversion
professional rich lady michelle obama
told america that she was oppressed
the criminally negligent governor of new
york bragged about how well he handled
the coronavirus
and then jeffrey epstein's old pal bill
clinton showed up to speak as the
party's moral voice
there has been a low-grade thrill in
watching all of this we'll admit at the
very least you've got to tip your hat to
their audacity
they don't tell small lies in the
democratic party they go
all the way you catch them stealing your
wallet and they arrest you for theft and
then they give you a lecture about how
crime doesn't pay
to longtime students of the liberal mind
none of this is new
the left long ago built an entire
political party based on the freudian
principle of transference
they displaced their own sins onto you
thereby cleansing their consciences
and allowing them to seize the moral
high ground it's a clever trick
but at this point it's an old trick we
know how it's done
the public certainly seems to have
figured it out last night the democrats
convention
lost in the ratings to a variety show
called america's got talent
a pair of jugglers from the philippines
brothers wearing glow-in-the-dark
headbands
did a yo-yo demonstration on stage and
that
out-rated dr jill biden by a lot
we could have told you that was going to
happen only nicole wallace wants to not
watch another speech by dr jill biden
by the way what kind of doctor is she
some of us aren't feeling well
we never learned that answer either what
the democrats should have done is put
the rest
of their proceedings on tv that would
get an audience
you might not know this but most of the
actual convention events take place
during daytime hours
the networks don't cover them you have
no idea they ever happened
there's a reason for that obviously but
what a loss
for the viewing public if you saw what
they were saying during the day you
would never tune in to prime time again
in fact you might flee the country
for the last three days we have watched
all of it in a moment we'll show you
what we found
we want to begin this evening by
bringing you a moment of prayer that
broke out at the convention on monday
a pastor called frederick haynes took
the microphone
as you listen to this compared to what
you might hear in your own church
you had the nerve to build a wall while
at the same time you have in
the harbor there in new york the statue
of liberty
saying give me your tired your huddled
masses yearning to breathe free
jesus will say america if you don't get
your act
together you can you may well go to hell
to hell vote for biden doom sinners or
you're going to hell
that is a pretty straightforward message
was jonathan edwards ever clearer than
that was jerry falwell
despite what you may have heard it is
the democratic party that is the hotbed
of religious extremism these days
pastor go to hell haynes for example is
a fan of minister louis farrakhan
these are men of faith just not your
faith
but religion is not the only institution
the democrats are reconfiguring at their
convention the pledge of allegiance
could use an overhaul
two they've decided and they're giving
it one watch the new
i pledge version to the flag of the
united states of america
and for the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty
and justice for all someday
someday right someday this could be a
good country someday
if we're in charge otherwise it's an
awful place
without us at the helm america is
terrible and not worth saving you've
heard this
before michelle obama once suggested it
the first time she was proud of her
country was when her family got to run
it
but that was nuanced by the standards of
today
at the democratic convention this week a
transgender rights activist called linda
labeja
just came out and said it explicitly
i've never felt american
i don't know the pledge of allegiance
those are not my systems the way that is
not my president
those are not their systems donald trump
is not their president meaning this is
not their country
as long as they dislike the guy in the
white house
so it's all or nothing for them and
right now they're trending toward
nothing
which is why they apparently turned over
the dnc stage directions to
colin kaepernick watch many of the
videos and pictures you're about to see
were recorded before
covet which is why the kids are not
social distancing
however the audio was recorded over the
past month
you may rise or kneel if you are able
for your preference
you can kneel so if you watch this stuff
for long enough and we have it's pretty
easy to forget that it's
pretty fringy actually look at the poles
most people don't agree with this
most americans like their country that's
why they live here
and a lot of them display that affection
by standing for the national anthem it
seems like a small thing
but it means quite a bit to people
americans have died in battle to protect
our national symbols
that is a talking point yes but it's not
just a talking point it really happened
but they don't know anything about that
at the democratic national convention
and they don't think that your kids
ought to know about it either
and that's why they've endorsed erasing
american history
may this moment in history manifest more
monuments like these to replace the old
ones
that no one really cares to see anymore
may their emergence and long overdue
establishment
and existence remind everyone of our
terrible ugly
and hurtful black world history
so there are parts of history that no
one cares to see anymore so we're
getting rid of it
you're keeping track at home if not
we're at erase american history
rewrite the pledge of allegiance mock
and degrade the national anthem
turn christianity into a political
weapon they have been
busy over there at the dnc but there's
more because now it's time for some
granular
policy discussions the details of how to
run the country
now we've showed you in previous nights
this week some of the dnc's platform
they want to get rid of a lot of the
country's prisons for example
they like to do away with bail for
accused criminals but that's just to
start just a little tasteful appetizer
before the main course
so for more we're going to go to someone
now called jay mai
you should know that jmi's preferred
pronouns are they them
according to their biography at wake
forest university jay mai is quote
a black vietnamese transgender
non-binary gender transcendent mermaid
queen king
currently living out their ever-evolving
truths in winston-salem
end quote got it okay now listen to j
mai
why can't folks imagine a world without
the cops why can't folks imagine a world
without prisons why can't people expand
their imaginations to include community
care to include an abolitionist future
um i'm talking about like for real for
abolition not just watered down
dnc version of abolition um we're
talking about abolishing the police
we're
talking about abolishing ice we're
talking about abolishing prisons
yeah we're talking about abolishing the
police abolishing ice abolishing all
prisons we're imagining a world like
that we're bringing it to you
you're starting to get some sense why
they're not putting the stuff on tv
democrats and their faithful lackeys the
media have been telling you for weeks
that none of this is
real you're imagining it democrats don't
really want to take the cops away and
leave you defenseless yes they are
voting to take billions from police
departments across the country
but that's not really defunding it's
redistributing
not a big deal calm down but now
jay mai shows up and lets an entire
animal shelter of cats
out of the dnc's bag and lets you know
that yes
all your fears are true we're doing
exactly
what you think we're doing the gender
transcendent mermaid queen kings are
here and it's a whole new deal now
get psyched and be sure to warn your
daughters
no more field hockey scholarships to
bowdoin for them no
there are boys on the field democrats
want biological men to compete with
girls in sports
most parents of girls think that's nuts
because it is
and terrible for girls because obviously
but at the democratic national
convention
it's not even questioned it's just
business as usual
watch transgender person marissa
richmond explain
we're going to have a panel looking at
trans youth issues
we've been watching state legislatures
especially here in the south
uh targeting uh trans youth uh for uh
trying to deny them access to health
care uh education
and and even access to the right to play
sports although
needless to say um the mishandling of
the coronavirus
by the current administration is
affecting a lot of people's ability to
play sports
but they've been particularly
transphobic in schools
okay so no more field hockey
scholarships and i'm sorry
your daughters are not going to make the
soccer team that's bad news
most people could live with it if they
had to but once again
it's just the beginning what if they
abolished capitalism
too would you like some bread lines to
go with that how about some
humiliation on the side it's all on the
menu listen to aspiring economist
ashley nicole mcrae this future that we
all want
that we're all trying to build um really
is about the destruction of colonization
white supremacy and capitalism
the destruction of colonization white
supremacy and capitalism
what does that mean exactly we're not
sure we're not delegates to the dnc
but we're pretty certain it's going to
be bad news for you
but not the end of the bad news no
there's more elizabeth warren showed up
to speak at the native american caucus
on tuesday
seems pretty likely she's come to steal
your horses
join us in fighting for joe biden and
kamala harris
and in supporting the democrats so that
we can
all continue our work for indian country
it's just so great our work for indian
country
we kept waiting for ralph northern to
show up at the dnc's african-american
panel wearing a hood
maybe that's tomorrow people online did
love the warren panel by the way loved
it in fact it probably would have
outraged the yo-yo brothers from the
philippines if they'd aired it at night
people at home flooded the dnc with
suggestions for chief warren
here's one if elizabeth warren can speak
at a native american event maybe millie
vanilli can host the grammy awards
that's not a bad idea actually but it
hurt elizabeth warren's feeling so the
dnc
shut down the chat room what a shame it
bears repeating by the way that not all
of this insanity was confined just to
the daytime some of it bled into prime
time as well
sandy cortez showed up to promise health
care college education
higher wages to illegal aliens she did
all of that
in a 90-second speech pretty impressive
it was like a socialist mad libs
competition
here's part of it thank you to everyone
here today endeavoring
towards a better more just future for
our country and our world
infidelity and gratitude to a mass
people's movement
working to establish 21st century social
economic and human rights including
guaranteed health care
higher education living wages and labor
rights
for all people in the united states i
hereby
second the nomination of senator bernard
sanders of vermont
for president of the united states of
america
let's put her in charge oh that's a good
idea whoa
we should note that crazy as all of this
was
and it was none of it was too crazy for
joe biden
or kamala hara sandy cortez called for
giving government health insurance to
foreign nationals tens of millions of
them
jay mai imagined a world without cops or
prisons
some lunatic and a cleric clerical
caller showed up and said republicans
are going to hell
harris and biden nodded along it all
seemed normal to them
because it is